To round things out, let's double-check the subtleties of your understanding of
inverse functions. I've written a bunch of statements here and I'd like you to
tell me which ones are true. Now, we may not have talked explicitly about every
single one of these. So, think about each of them carefully, and if you need to
try more than once, that is completely fine, as always. You can check off as
man as you want to, even all of them, if you think that that's appropriate. So
here are your choices. All functions have inverses. All inverse functions have
inverses. A functions domain can influence whether or not it has an inverse.
All functions pass the vertical and horizontal line tests. And lastly, all
inverse functions pass the vertical and horizontal line tests.